Top Gun did ridiculous business but did
Tom Cruise reach out to you personally
and say John I'm a fan I want you in
this film I got to meet Tom Cruise For
the First Time at Jimmy Kimmel's house
nice uh to walk on a Sunday to watch
football right he would have these these
these big groups and they'd have a keg
and he'd make pizzas and it was La so
it's sunny and the game start at 10 in
the morning and
big group of comedy writers and comics
and actors and people in them and the
Rumor was going like you know Tom Cruise
is supposed to come by today
I'm like no he's not that's what I'm
talking about that's like saying Santa
Claus is coming like there's no way that
that is and you're an idiot if you
believe that and Jimmy famously is a
very big prankster you're a fool if you
think that that is actually going to
happen and not only does the doorbell
ring
and
unmistakably it is it's not a Tom Cruise
impersonator it is Tim Tom Cruise
with his mom
shows up at football
and and so we got Tom Cruise and Mom
Cruz and it's like we this is
uh we're all having like an out of body
experience and like this is the arguably
the most famous person on the planet
absolutely is in this living room
watching you know nine football games at
once and so that's how I had met Tom and
and then I got you know to say five
words to him and and uh he he had seen
Mad Men because he kind of was like I
like I you know in the very Tom Cruise
way like very direct and intense and I
love that show I love that you're I love
that show thanks man holy cow like it
was a that was a good day that was a
really good day
um so then so then you know cut to
however many years later God 10 years
later
um I'm driving down the road and my my
phone rings and I I yeah hello it's my
agent hey they you know they're coming
at you for uh they want you to do a part
in in the in the Top Gun sequel
and I was like well then the answer is
yes are you crazy no-brainer yes I want
yes I want to well we don't know the
money and this and that it's not this
and that I was like no no no no no no
the answer is yes
you work out the details but the answer
is yes if this goes away
you're all fired like there's no there's
no version of of the if they've asked me
to be in this which by the way was still
kind of a new
thing for me of like being asked to be a
part of something not only that is so
front and center in the cultural
everything but to me
was one of my favorite movies of all
time right so to actually get to kind of
flash back to being that point 13 14
years old 1985.
and and and be asked to be a part of the
next chapter of this and then basically
have all of my scenes be with Tom Cruise
I was like no this is there's this is
no-brainer this is a no-brainer the
answer is yes I'm sure it will be a big
hit and it was
foreign